[Music]
reality is something walls in crete
cambitious of science and general
that again to purchase it keep reality on
it jacket out you can be explained
and how things management
where can you apply laws of nature
but now of tassel 5 quantum mechanics
and could we can  i seem to turn fresh site to
cook and direction
upside on then they file the
counters fitness and they to what if i weigh
right very clear distinction
what about fitness of the world that
jessie ring holders
and the fitness innowave describing the
world
so much just haven't  yet on their job
completely de foil foil partial
solution to the question why distraught
fixen heey what's happening jansen is
how je donal dat de desley hassle is mee
productions en de alle predictions aveve
je cf vd de weather forecast and
television op wat have so see that  he
her 40% chance of rain lord sometimes hang
percent chaucer huge de ca and it
chances of range of sunshine and she to
whom aren't sure picasso f4i dull
imperfect
or  matter earth damsels is far too
complex the sphinx and thinks there is a dot
dot
imminent five words point if you
sit public world is realist i am
a laws of nature when oil about real
things happening you hate you take that all
the way this was find  and again year
discussions about this subject
we wonder a typical yes we do vr free
will to do des en free world that act with which
girl movies and series sedation
are white within the free well what free
will free will is if we torrent but
at least that  class or nature who dono
like or quasi donk
are you someone who have already limitations
weekend covered avian briefing is
moment that's already fixed at balance and
you know and that shoot of acacias fishing
chippy the v hook what that blow if
fest that requirement don't  up to this most
out of what 4 you first colt
quantum mechanical
if so sam vs ipad erwin aan danny k two
way incredibly i that the chance to
models off opinion the cash register moda very
good en in practice the  deep addictions
week and mika im imagining
perfect
so that the dough it your account dan the
crèche or qubits story the crèche and where
who raises cube where i just
get all tellson's better understand this week and
create
fitness in the neighborhood reverse your two
andy's compete  the fingers is gold
and time moment even that can have
which means of je die long way to go
when a voice by that minister class
in fact assink who hb were misled
fantastic
features of mathematics at world is
themes descried that fantastic with the
medical the  kitchens mathematicians no
trade
so can there incredibly die de qualys
never commuting numbers and that dory deed
in mathematics week and describe and tag
still very very well and our met
with is tellson's this fantastic
symmetry in this world
all promos so in frieze much too
large prince and unfortunately our belief is
it is an orientations
the know oil and rectum nominated to
orientations in the will
da  t is we strange reshoot great that you
can also eat there also nice to
new you like and yet another rotation
hair comb the party casino you have you there
additions when scrolls symmetry
there is rotation in fresh in the world
police is then dad the right  size is
but this is not to party or boxes ria
cunning always what you want to
describe a d and dismiss
finally work to be done why is this so
in gates discretion
the goose in the buy 9 discussions beep
it out of the time year could station  was
dead bait craft city crash a piece if
you can
check it experimentally that is straw de
death note ii kulargument i if you can
still still to investigate realism is
important for a question of model
building
arm as if they the or the world da
imperfect  apps where the quantum mechanics
that you pose act we need to have some
dropped a one on the leads that he around the
use is supposed is complete the
realistic wat hoe dat goal models
rtf 2d
ho chi minh pr  practice understanding of fashion b
later and interviews
subscribe to day to the institute as
to who is ah tv